good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday the
thursday of the longest week of all time
hey claude how are you doing
hello jacqueline this is literally the
longest week of all time thank you so
much for pointing that out yeah no i
felt it to be important last night i was
sitting in bed and i was like it's only
wednesday this is
criminal and then
my night really took a turn for the
worst and we are a little late on
delivering today's podcast and i just
need to own up to that and explain what
happened here starting at 4 a.m my smoke
detector alarm started going off beeping
once every 30 seconds i was like laying
in bed up timing it and it just stabbed
we had to change the battery and it was
atrocious i was up from four to five
because i couldn't fall back asleep with
it in the background it
like it didn't keep me up after that but
like it was so annoying i had white
noise on i had my noise cancelling
airpods and i could still hear it and i
was like well we definitely can't
podcast if that's going to beep once
every 30 seconds i will drive people
insane
no that's a particular type of torture
especially if you're trying to sleep
yeah and i was just like so worried
about bruno but i checked in on him and
he was sleeping like a little baby i
guess it was just me these days i'm a
light sleeper it's the body's way of
getting you ready for motherhood so i've
heard so i wake up at anything and then
i can't fall back asleep
touch
touch but here we are and
it's off so i have peace in my home
there's nothing like peace in your own
home no there is not how are you doing
i'm good we have a great episode for you
guys oh i got a haircut
you didn't really like say anything
since we've been on this interface well
i actually i didn't notice it when you
were combing your hair which is like a
new thing that you like to do while we
podcast from home
well okay podcasting from home i don't
have a desk my desk quote unquote is my
family all my makeup so i'm sitting in
front of like you know combs brushes
makeup makeup brushes how am i not
supposed to touch them and use them i
know it's really it's trying
but
it's extremely trying i did see your new
layers and i was like i'll wait till the
show to address the haircut in the room
and it looks so fabulous
thank you it's like a very subtle
haircut but for me it's like i feel like
a completely different woman and it's
like is everyone looking at my hair i
think that they are i actually knew that
you were coming on here with your fresh
haircut so i was like okay i have to do
my hair today and i need something to
cover my big fat face because yesterday
was just a whole lot of face
so i did my hair and i have you to thank
for that
it's a pleasure i have you to thank for
making me so you know that song
no gavin degraw
mm-hmm oh my god you haven't lived
no i'm so sorry where is gavin we need
new music
looking for gavin we're a very low-key
guy constantly you know coming up for
air and then going back down it's been a
while since we got new music it always
slaps he's one of my favorite artists
probably of all time like he's like
kelly clarkson level to me in that like
pantheon of just can do no wrong and i
would like to put it out there like to
manifest in like the word the buzzword
of
2022 i'd like to manifest some new gavin
degraw music
it's not going to happen unless you say
it out loud
that's not how i roll but that's what
the kids are doing they're manifesting
things
and there's something to all of this i
don't know they really think they're
doing something and i'm not convinced
but i don't want to yuck i don't want to
yuck someone's yums and what and one
member of the manifestation crew is the
snatcher
and so i just i'm going to leave it at
that
speaking of not doing something i do
have to let you know that i did not
watch the real housewives of orange
county last night what happened
i went out to dinner and it just like it
wasn't in the cards it wasn't in the
kurds okay well i watched this week and
last week so i'm all caught up and i
will give you my thoughts it's pretty
good it's all over the place and i just
need to parse out how i'm feeling but i
feel like it has the makings of like
really good groundwork for a really good
season just this noella girl is
confused she's off the charts she's
confusing i'm confused and
we will have to break it down so i'm
that's sad that you didn't watch but
everyone's entitled it wasn't it wasn't
oh
what mad i have this handheld mirror and
i remember last night when i was like
doing my makeup the handheld mirror fell
off my table and i just realized it's
completely shattered is that seven years
of bad luck it depends if you subscribe
to those notions
okay so i don't yeah no i use a handheld
mirror that is cracked that's been
cracked for two years and i still use it
every day so i guess that's technically
bad luck i should throw it away but i
don't want it it still works i can still
see myself
oh that but now i'm just like looking at
the mirror and it's haunting me throw it
away
i will now that i know about it not your
problem
not my problem
well we have a lot to talk about today
and then we'll recap real housewives of
orange county i also started a new book
last night
eight months in i'm finally reading my
first pregnancy book
oh good it's called expecting better by
emily oster my doctor recommended it and
so far i'm really enjoying it but like
all of my dreams last night were like
pregnancy statistics yeah and that's
just not somewhere i want to be so i'm
going to try and read it like more in
the afternoon and not right before bed
otherwise like my brain is going into
like
charts mode
yeah no you're consumed with the
pregnancy yeah but and i'm every time
i'm like reading a new chapter i'm like
[ __ ] i should have read this in the
beginning
but no one really like vehemently
recommended
any books to me and so far like
everything that she's saying that you
should do like um there's nothing that
was like oh [ __ ] i did that and i
shouldn't have except for the time i um
tuna fish
i just it was what was it good
you know it wasn't once it was twice and
um
it was good but i hope those mercury
levels i hope everything's okay
i think you're okay okay but if not
blame ben he forced it off of course
when in doubt blame ben 100 how is
benjamin for anything
he's doing very very well
um he's not here right now which is why
it's so quiet and just a p like perfect
way
environment for podcasting because ben's
toxic energy is not here i understand
completely and you have the peace we
have dew and
brew in the background and they we do
have a live studio audience so that's
really exciting everyone's been asking
us to like get people fan fridays are
back fan fridays are back two seats do
and
brew sometimes maybe if her mother will
allow it magoo okay miss magoo
um so yeah i think we should dive in i
have uh
nothing to say in the tv recap but lots
to say elsewhere okay so without further
ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp betterhelp is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online you
shouldn't wait till things get
unbearable before you go to therapy it's
a tool to utilize before things get
worse and it can help you avoid those
lows
better help is sponsoring today's
episode and our listeners will get 10
off their first month of better
um when they go to betterhelp.com
toast that's betterhelp b e t t e r h e
l p dot com toast for 10 off their first
month
check it out
wonderful
so what do we got for the for the first
story oh is it the picture of kim p it
is i hate to lead with the same story
like three days in a row but this is
just developing breaking news and
we asked and we received pictures of kim
and pete catching rays together in the
bahamas so displaying different
approaches to dressing for the region
kim kardashian and pete davidson were
snapped enjoying each other's company in
the bahamas on wednesday paparazzi
caught the two walking on a dock
together after disembarking from a boat
for their daytime date kim wore an
all-black ensemble a plunging black top
that looked like a one-piece bathing
suit um with a black louis vuitton
backpack and slip
with um
sorry he was wearing that she was
wearing a black plunging black top and
baggy distressed denim paired with
matching shades and he was wearing a
blue letterman jacket with cream-colored
sweats underneath and his louis vuitton
backpack okay i'm sorry kim's jeans were
out of control do you know how hot it is
in the bahamas like what are you doing i
i'm hesitant to comment on kim's fashion
because i feel like you know i'm
commenting on michelangelo
painting the system chapel 100 who am i
but what like this was
no but the outside of the environment
that she was in the outfit is you know
like objectively cute but what are you
wearing big old jeans for on the beach i
have no
freaking clue that was really shocking
they they're so mismatched neither of
them they don't look like they're going
to the same place and neither of them
look like they're in the bahamas
the jeans were really shocking but again
like i really try to just
let go and like let kim do her fashion
thing and i'm sure like in two years
i'll be wearing baggy jeans on the beach
because that's just how i can actually
assure you that i will never be doing
that and like looking at those pictures
was giving me armpits wet i'm like do
these people not get warm yeah no it was
it wasn't the aesthetic that i was
looking for but i'm still happy to to
have the pictures well it was a
watershed moment it's the first photo of
them
that i've seen that's like somewhat vis
like the one that we have from you know
knott's berry farm or whatever it's
called
was blurry and dark like for me this is
a real photo of them and it's high
quality and it's it's like crazy well we
have we have a few things like we've had
like fans like seeing them at the movie
theaters in staten island where like
they were together we had you know them
with flavor flav flavor but yeah this
these are like photos that should be
iconic but the outfits are making them
iconic for the wrong reasons no these
are photos that should be iconic but the
outfits are making them moronic yeah
yeah and it and it pains me to say to
say that but but i do believe this is
the first paparazzi photo of them
correct
um together
i can't i can't decipher what's
paparazzi and what's like fans
no i'm not talking about fans but the
fans have gotten some good stuff of them
yeah but it's not like premium like this
is really premium like i could see you
know the pores on kim's face like it's
really high quality yeah but the the
outfits are so low quality it it really
took away from this really special
moment i agree it's an extremely
confusing photo because you would see
those two people and you'd be like oh
they're going to
a winter wonderland themed party and
then they're literally on the beach yeah
also she posted a selfie like a bikini
selfie today so it's like she's you know
doing the vacation thing where was that
picture where's that paparazzi photo
she's posting in real time yeah no but
it's like okay so you're wearing a
bikini in the bahamas like can we see
that
right right right like where did the
jeans go where did the jeans go they
need to go into i mean incinerator
and that's just insane to me they were
the biggest pair of jeans they probably
take up so much space in her suitcase
like how does she have space to pack
other things
yeah those are some big jeans
they're enormous i hope that that trend
just does not trickle down to me
honestly but but i can't help you never
know you never you really never know and
i'm sure in two years i will look back
at this and be clowning on myself but i
really don't think i just want to say
like i never just like the jeans like i
think objectively they look cute it's
just an un
necessary place to be wearing them
beyond
beyond okay yeah yeah it definitely took
away from this really special moment
though it is still incredibly special
agreed
are you ready for our next story some
more kardashian news these are the only
people making news these days and i was
thinking about it and i was like you
know what i think it is because when i'm
reading the stories it's like either
it's the kardashians and like
what their farts smell like or it's like
every celebrity has covered right now
no you're right they're the only people
keeping it interesting in hollywood and
they're putting the industry and the
town on their back but it's because i
think like everyone has coveted so
they're not and i mean like so and so
having covered like isn't news
so
they're all we're talking about
yeah i thought of that yesterday how
like literally our whole show was always
about the kardashians we it comes in
waves but i do feel like this week in
particular because everyone else is sort
of out of commission
100
but cory gamble is showing off support
for tristan thompson with a jersey with
his name on it amid the paternity
scandal
kris jenner's boyfriend corey gamble
made a surprising show of support for
tristan on tuesday holding up the nba
players number 13 jersey for paparazzi
in la
gambell had attended thompson's
sacramento kings losing game against the
la lakers which came on the heels of him
copping to the paternity suit against
him
wait tristan plays for the sacramento
kings yeah i learned that yesterday too
that's really sad
where was he last playing he was playing
in boston
yeah and the cavaliers at one point but
so sacramento's i mean if they were
still trying to work in new york it's in
new york i mean not new york i love
sacramento new york this time of year
so it's in california yes logistically
i'm just talking about like his career i
didn't know that like the way that i
perceive the nba and again that's just
this is just my own unique
um pov
it's like the sacramento kings no shade
to their fans is like one of the most
like broke down
unwell like franchises it used to be
owned by the maloofs
i never have spent time thinking about
the sacramento kings and if you asked me
two days ago what the sacramento team
name was i don't know if i could have
given you an answer
well that was the other thing i was like
and maybe i'm actually just making this
up i was pretty sure the sacramento
kings changed their name did they not
why would they change it
they were in desperate need of a rebrand
you're asking the wrong girl
but i don't guess if the article says
the sacramento kings it doesn't i don't
think that they did there's a lot
there's been a lot of changes with
sports teams but i think it's like more
so like the la rams the chargers like
those football teams i haven't seen not
that i would see but i haven't heard
about uh basketball teams
no i just like
in my mind i was living in a world where
they changed their name but in the
actual world i don't think that that
happened i don't think it happened too
but tristan did join the team and chloe
and corey seems to be supporting him
what are your thoughts people are
extremely pressed
i'm extremely disappointed in cory i'm
not really sure what he he he was
signaling like
is it
you know
what was he saying with the jersey like
i
i can't imagine how someone can even
defend tristan that's why i'm like
struggling with i think i think what
he's saying with the jerseys like
tristan's my boy and he's made mistakes
but like he's still
family yeah or even friend
and i have to be honest i know people
like are enraged about this sort of and
expect like me to have that same energy
but this doesn't really bother me like
if the whole family were like supporting
him and having his name sorry it bothers
me i would be confused but like if one
member of the family like wants to stand
by tristan or like be there for him
okay
agreed if it comes like actually like in
a person on a personal sense like
standing by them but you know like chloe
has been so publicly embarrassed by this
man so many [ __ ] times that right now
he doesn't really
need anyone like publicly standing up
for him like that actually pisses me off
and i'm really disappointed in corey
because he should know better
yeah
i don't know i mean i just would hope
that like whatever like that it's clo
that chloe is fine with this and i feel
like she might be i feel like she
doesn't want everyone to just up and
leave him you know if he if him and
corey are really good friends
then maybe cory should be there for him
and he just like showed off the jersey
and i don't know it didn't really like
bother me so much maybe it should
no it's just and cory is a king so like
i just trust his judgment
well that's the thing cory is a king so
it's like where is he going with this
i think he's like going to be like a
good friend you know
but it's just not adding up
but what if they were like really good
friends before and now he's like me
obviously made this mistake what do you
do
it's tough but you side with the family
always
yeah but maybe they're not requiring
people to take sides i don't know it's
just different because it's true dad
he's never he's not going anywhere
really right that's the thing this
person's in their life forever um and i
have to imagine cory is very much like a
peacemaker in the family
yes and constantly bringing people
together so i i imagine that that's this
is his way of doing that but it's too
soon okay that's fair
yeah
are you ready for our next story
yes ma'am chris noth is being cut from
and just like that season finale he
filmed in paris and those scenes are now
cut amount amid sexual assault
allegations the upcoming season finale
for and just like that will reportedly
no longer feature chris noth his
character mr big previously spoiler
alert
big spoiler died in the first episode um
but they were screen they were seen
photographed filming in paris and he was
supposed to be in the season finale and
now he will not be wow
flashback not that i watch yeah maybe
now no more i mean this really doesn't
disrupt the storyline at all if he's
already dead right so it's not really
not a big deal they're really doing
anything or making any hard decisions
they're so brave like you're cutting a
dead person out they're so brave
yeah i agree i don't really care like
now that he's dead bye
yeah
okay well
we were curious to see what sort of
position they would take on everything
that happened they all put out some
lukewarm statements and now they're
cutting him from a scene that was
probably irrelevant to begin with so
still doing the least
you know i was gonna say the three of
them did like pen a letter together
supporting the women who spoke forward
um
but yeah very much not making a thing of
this
yeah
okay cool have you still been watching
the show
i have
um the
new episode came out today so i
obviously haven't seen that yet but the
most recent episode like was kind of
crazy really
yeah i still stand by that like i
um
i don't know if you i honestly can't
tell if you would like it because some
episodes are really good and some
episodes are really bad but for the most
part like i really just am enjoying it
it's a quality show like with quality
writing quality characters who you've
known and loved for years and it's just
like a fun thing to go on and honestly
the best part is when new episodes come
out like people's hot takes on on tick
tock are really premium because so much
of the [ __ ] that goes down in the show
was so unbelievably stupid
and it's fun to see people all over the
world talking about it on tick tock
that's fun and you do love to be a part
of something
precisely okay so you're a part of this
i still don't think i will watch it i
came close to starting emily in paris
last night and i was just like
no seriously like i'm telling you don't
i would rather read a book by an
economist about the statistics of
pregnancy that's where really where i
went i was like i do not have
i just i'm on such a different
wavelength than emily do you know what i
mean and as you should be because emily
is an unwell
disturbed
sociopath it's the worst [ __ ] show
and i really don't think you should
bring that energy into your pregnancy
right now like you're an extremely
sensitive time in your life so i
honestly don't know if i'm going to
watch it because i had the opportunity i
had the time i had the energy and i
chose not to so it might have just
removed itself from my content plate
seriously don't do it like for real i
wish i could get back those eight hours
oh by the way are you following this
jeopardy thing
no but i saw that you are and i want you
to explain it to me
okay so there's a contestant who is her
name is amy and she
side note was also recently just robbed
which was very bizarre that's what i saw
yeah but beyond that she had gained like
some some fame because she's on her way
to
i think last night was her 26th win in a
row she's almost at a million dollars
one
she's
so smart like i watched last night's
episode jackie it wasn't even like a
competition like she was ahead by thirty
thousand dollars it is it's just like
it's oh and ken jennings is hosting
currently he's the
person who currently holds the most
wins how many wins in her way how many
wins and how much money does ken
jennings have
i'm not entirely sure
um let's google ken's ken jennings win
streak here and second question was the
right oh my god what
he won 74 shows and 2.5 million dollars
damn
and my next question amy what's her name
was the robbery related at all to this
current jeopardy streak
no it's just incredibly like weird
timing because she's in la filming these
episodes
wow that's crazy and she's okay
she's okay she's okay to the show
she's okay she was
she was okay her name is amy schneider
and she is
i think in her 20th win
she's got no always 26th that's what you
said she's got a ways to go if she's
gonna beat ken jennings at his own game
but i feel like if he's a host now he's
gonna try and trip her up
but i'm telling you he's not gonna let
her
this woman couldn't be stopped and you
know what i knew a jeopardy clue last
night
from like the crown what was it so the
the category was antonym
and it was uh the a was in quotes so
they were giving definitions of words
and you had to guess
the antonym of that definition that
starts with an a
so it was to take the throne so the
antonym of taking the throne abdic
abdicating the throw and they didn't get
it i was literally screaming at my
[ __ ] tv i'm like abdicate [ __ ]
educate amy didn't get it
no it was chantal one of the girls oh my
god stressful
and by the way amy's so good
she's not even just winning like they
literally interrupted the game last
night and was like oh you know she
guessed
for the same category she guessed
ambiguous when the answer was actually
um
another word that starts with a
arbitrary and
oh yes oh my god very good
so she guessed ambiguous which wasn't
the correct answer and then like two
minutes later the judges were like
actually your answer was technically
correct amy and they gave her the money
wow so she's changing
[Music]
she's so smart she's changing the game
right like she's creating answers that
even the experts didn't even think of
damn i hope she goes far but i know that
ken's not gonna let her beat him
she already has gone far and that is so
funny no but like she
she has ways to go if she wants to you
know come for ken's throne
no but it's just been a really long time
since i think someone has made this many
um
this long of a run and what's her what's
her personal story what's her background
what does she do she's she's a trans
woman
and she's an engineering manager
and i'm not sure what that means like
does she have hobbies that
have allowed her to know all this stuff
i didn't read her autobiography but i do
wonder people who are
how do they know well-versed in trivia
like how do they know
all of this is it part of their job is
it just like for fun
no and some people definitely have like
niche knowledge on random trivia but
like you to know everything from like
architecture to plants composers to pop
culture even like there's sometimes more
often than not like current events so i
don't know i don't know what you do for
a living or what your interests are that
get you to know that much stuff yeah
okay
unless you work in academia
yes but even still you would have a
specialized
subject subject
makes you think unless you're like a
homeroom teacher and
[Laughter]
okay are you ready for our next story
only if it's a story that's brought to
you by manscaped cheers to the new year
and making resolutions you can actually
keep have you added self-care to your
routine our sponsors at manscape have
the perfect tools to help keep you and
your significant other clean and tidy
this year
manscape tools for his jewels are so
good you'll want them for yourself the
lawnmower mower 4.0
is all you'll need for his balls and
your bikini line set your first new
year's resolution with good intentions
and join the four million people
worldwide who trust manscaped with our
exclusive offer so you go to
manscape.com and you use the code toast
you'll get 20 off and free shipping
they have tons of products at manscaped
obviously the performance package 4.0 is
one of their most popular where they um
have the lawnmower it's an electric
trimmer that's designed with skin safe
technology to reduce cuts it comes
equipped with a 400k led light um it
shines super bright the products are
so great they're electric products they
have great skincare products they also
have cute travel cases perfect for the
man in your life and in turn the perfect
gift for yourself
you'll be upgrading both you and his
grooming routine this year and using the
best tools for the job whether your
resolution is to work out more travel to
new places be sure to travel to
manscape.com for the exclusive offer of
20 off plus free shipping with code
toast again get 20 off and free shipping
with codetoast.manscape.com
that's 20 off free shipping at
manscaped.com
use code toast wonderful
our next story the 2022 grammy awards
have been postponed due to the
uncertainty surrounded coven 19 omicron
varian so the grammys are postponed
until further notice the recording
academy and cbs announced announced in a
joint statement on wednesday that the
award show would be postponed amid the
ongoing covet surge
so does that mean they're not announcing
like the nominees either i i don't know
i guess not i mean i'm sure they're
hoping that they can do it like a month
later or something and just move on but
they're gonna have to make some
decisions soon
right because it's like you're [ __ ]
with the timetable of like when
when music released is considered for
what years yeah
yeah and then eventually like if they
put it on too long like then we're into
the next year and
i mean maybe they should just do it
without a show and just like announce
the nominations and that's just taking
me back to such dark times yeah
yeah it's so upsetting and also like
we're coming into awards season so if
the grammys are already you know putting
the brakes on then i'm sure first of all
that and golden globes isn't even
happening
yeah but that has nothing to do with
kovac that has to do with them being a
fraudulent organization but then the
other shows like who wants to be the one
show that's you know they all sort of
follow each super spreader so
this is crazy news for the grammy world
and also like a bummer for any big
artists of this year who would have been
you know olivia rodrigo olivia rodrigo
yeah yeah totally so we'll keep you
posted on that and our fifth and final
story
if you're ready for it why don't you
sing it today and i'll play percussion
okay okay
it's the final story
[Music]
it's
not
it doesn't sync up
we'll go acapella
it doesn't that's a magic number no
that's the instrumental version
oh that's what i meant not acapella
[ __ ] damn it doesn't say god it's like
i don't even know music
truly
our fifth and final story is a little
coachella news
kanye west billy eilish will headline
coachella and swedish house mafia has
been added to the mix so we recently
reported that travis scott who was set
to headline coachella is no longer
headlining and instead billy
billy eilish and kanye are slated to
headline the 2022 coachella festival and
now
also as an aside swedish house mafia has
been added to the bill
so
also this is another situation where
it's like who even knows if coachella is
going to happen at this point
oh right but
let's operate as if it is
oh my god this is so depressing like i
refuse to give it i'm like for real it's
happening just like let it be are you
gonna go to coachella
no i know you i'm not saying i want it
to happen because like i care about the
music
i just like i cannot i'm getting so many
bad vibes this week like yeah no you
just want to keep moving forward
i just want to keep live events
yes on yes but i mean this is like if
assuming coachella happens this is a
great news for the fans i mean billy
eilish has performed a number of times
and kanye will be a great headliner so i
feel like
it all it all works out
so if
if i asked you in your opinion
who
what is swedish house mafia what would
you say to that
that's a really interesting question
i would say that they are the original
like house music guys i think it's
totally i think it's three people
and do you know who any of them are
that's my i just know that like one of
them
i believe at one point
had a wife who was on the show on e
about europeans living in l.a
what that is not what i was expecting
you to do that's what i think about i
need to google it
well because i'd like wanted to tell you
the three people in swedish house mafia
are already on their own all three
enormous djs it's axwell steve angelo
and sebastian engrosso and i just
thought that was interesting like yeah
no i'm 100 right i just googled it
isabelle adrian she was on europe
euros of hollywood
damn he has really tried a lot of crap
over the years to like remain relevant
after the kardashians
and she is married to steve angelo and
so she was like there were
some of the other people in the cast
either were djs or you know had like dj
associations and she was the creme de la
creme because she was married to steve
angelo's swedish house mafia
you'd think like she'd be too good for
that show yeah honestly the show was
pretty good
everything on e just like is so sad no
he has had some good shows and i don't
know why they get
why they can't get their [ __ ] together
yeah there were some really interesting
cast members
on oh yeah
have you heard of bleona do you ever
watch a show
leona is like a huge never even heard of
it leona is a huge um albanian singer
she's like the share of albania
wow it's like caprice from ladies of
london yeah no it was a really good show
justice
justice for euros of hollywood i didn't
see myself going down that road today
you know what's so weird like
i don't think i can remember a time when
you brought up like a cultural reference
that i've never heard of
i've never heard of the show it was only
i think it was a one season wonder
your favorite i mean that's the only
shows i watch
no but there's something about a like
someone i don't understand like what
goes on there
but they are doing a new show i saw a
commercial um
relatively famous where it's like
children of famous people are like going
to a farm or something so it's trying to
be like filthy rich cattle drive
yeah it's giving like i'm a celebrity
get me out of here
okay who's on it anyone we know
i the commercial was like
really poorly produced because they
didn't tell me any of the famous people
who were on oh well we could also just
google it
relatively
famous cast
ranch rules yeah
okay i don't know any of these people
oh really mm-hmm
like in a
well that makes it like not
fun but it seems like a good idea
yeah it does seem like a good idea
but i mean maybe when they explain who
they are like but i mean the only name i
recognize there's one hasselhoff
um
but not the one from rich kids
was there hasselhoff and rich kids i
think so haley
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
i was actually thinking about rich kids
in beverly hills yesterday great show
great show
great launching platform for so many of
my favorite people to follow on
instagram 100 percent agreed
um
so the first password
i feel as though you very much needed to
know them
and now we're gonna get into the tv
recap yeah
i wouldn't say very much needed to know
the stories like you kind of could know
yeah no that's just like what
what you should could know sure
right
yes so you're going to tell me
everything that happened on the real
houses of orange county so i don't have
to watch it
brought to you by bowling branch no one
wants to cut corners on what's important
and few things matter more than a good
night's sleep poland branch's signature
sheets feel so soft and light you'll
forget you're not actually sleeping on a
cloud and they're sustainably made for
uncompromising quality from field to
factory so you know our beds are very
very important to us and
we spend a lot of time in them and i
feel like it makes us somewhat experts
on what's good in the bedroom department
and honestly i bowling brand sheets on
my bed right behind me it's one of my
favorite brands everything i have
sheets duvet cover pillowcases i have a
throw throw blankets like i really
just bought the whole website out the
best product they keep me so cool at
night i'm a sweater in my sleep
and they only use 100 sustainable raw
materials um
so you know that your product feels good
it looks good it's doing good and the
sheets that i have are the signature hem
sheets they're their best sellers
they're buttery soft lightweight organic
cotton um they're not too hot and not
too cool so they're the perfect sheets
for year-round sleepers and bowling
branch focuses on quality over quantity
so there's no inflated thread counts
more because more isn't always better
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlingbranch.com and get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code toast to check out that's
bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code toast
great thank you now it is time for the
tv recap so i watched both episodes of
oc last night and i can't really you
know piece together what was from last
week or this week which is fine
so noella like we're literally like one
two three days out from her divorce and
just like seeing how she's behaving and
like what she's doing she goes to like
lunch you know looks like a nice weather
from lunch nicole
with nicole and she at first it seemed
like noel is kind of like getting really
emotional and nicole is like let's get
out of here because like i guess nicole
like doesn't like public displays of
emotion but then upon like watching the
the flashbacks it's clear that like
noella was just like drinking so much
and was just like having a breakdown
like emotionally and also just like
being drunk and nicole was like being
the sort of friend i guess she wasn't
being like so cuddly and like
keeping and like comforting but it was
just like we need to get the [ __ ] out of
here like you're they're already there
it was such a crowded restaurant they're
already showing up with cameras and like
this girl is having an actual breakdown
like i kind of really appreciated
nicole's approach
so i watched that episode the one from
two weeks ago and i actually didn't see
it that way i actually thought nicole
was being hella rude and now like
knowing now that noella was probably
super drunk i still think nicole was
[ __ ] rude no like they showed
flashbacks of like all the times noella
ordered a drink so it's clear that they
were there for a very long time so it's
not like she just started crying and she
was like let's you know let's split
right but she was just being quite
emotional i find the whole noella
divorcing i mean it's really first of
all it's bizarre to come onto a show and
then episode two like your husband's
serving you but i went to noella's
instagram because um i just wanted to
see like how thirsty she is compared to
you know she said jen was really thirsty
which was one of the funniest reads of
all time like coming for her for tagging
her in a photo of herself which i
actually i would never say to someone
but that is such a red flag as a as a
textbook thirst textbook thirst like
here's a picture of myself and i'm going
to tag all of the like semi-influential
people that i know like i know it's
weird no it's so weird but i would never
actually let someone know that's why i
didn't like them so i
but i understood completely what noella
was saying anyway so i was like i'll go
to her instagram and see like what she's
about and it turns out that
when her and her husband signed up for
the show they had to go through a
background check and the background
check exposed his tax issues and i guess
that given that he wanted to pull out
from the show and was like insisting
that they pull out and she felt like and
these are her words that you know the
show at that point was the only thing
holding him accountable for all of his
lies and you know everything was coming
to light so then he splits and now she's
like left picking up the pieces and i'm
just finding it
i ki i mean i hate to agree with her but
i'm kind of with jen
where it's like this isn't adding up
like the whole thing is so
crazy
and i feel like some of the women just
want to be there for her and
i appreciate that and that's a really
sweet thing to do but like there's
something we've seen so many housewives
like go through it that at this point
that like now i'm skeptical and i'm
cynical and i'm just like
there's something weird here jen says
that they're not actually married i
think that they i don't think that
that's true because like she did get
served with papers but like her just
reactions to everything and like
i'm just not fully buying it i think
there's like so much more to this story
i can't even fathom what the truth could
be also it seems like a lot of the women
are like slowly turning on noella like
heather is because noella likes to talk
a little bit of crap about heather she
like called her fake two times and got
back to heather
heather gets like is pretty chummy with
jen
and obviously jen and noella are like
oil and water so i watched the episode
and you know heather went over to jen's
house and like i just find it so amusing
how everyone acts around heather like so
desperate to be her friends so desperate
to make a connection so desperate to be
relevant and the gen scene like was
uncomfortable i'm not gonna lie
yeah i didn't expect them to get along
but i guess anyone who like acts in
deference to heather is going to be a
friend of heather's
speaking of gina but i actually really
like their friendship they went to the
racetrack and i i considering i really
like gina and emily like if they i just
i think
they're friends with heather more than
just because she's like heather dubrow i
think gina and heather like just are two
people who naturally click and like you
can't help who you click with so 100
the dynamics are interesting because
they're like shifting and there's like
a lot of
cross-contamination like there's no
clear sides or anything but there's
people who are just like aren't getting
along with other people but there are
also some real friendships forming so
i think that that is a good
playing field for the rest of
the season
but we need to figure out what's going
on with noella
there's something about noella
yeah she
it's
it's something's off
for sure with her story
i will catch up on that because actually
i'm interested also her husband was like
on tick tock like making all these
videos like
addressing confronting like [ __ ] that
she said about him on the show
yep and they're like going back and
forth on instagram like putting out
videos about like what's happening and
who's been there for their kid and like
how you know her credit cards are cut
off and all she has is a credit card on
amazon
and instacart and that's how she's
gotten by and it's like
this is a lot of information for people
who you didn't like for fans who have
been around for four weeks
it's a lot
so
i'm
i'm cautious i'm not like fully just
like
feeling one way or another yeah
well
thank you for the debrief
thank you for being you thank you for
shining a light in this world
and thank you guys for listening to the
morning toast for me
oh my god i like need a manicure
thank you guys so much for listening
to
me too
no i haven't had one since omicron came
to town mm-hmm
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast and atlanta morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast and where podcasts can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart radio cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us this morning chosen
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing day and we'll
see you tomorrow for friday that is so
exciting you guys one more day one more
sleep till friday one more day of alarm
living until we hit that weekend we will
see you tomorrow have a good one
bye